Renfield
the person in life is to serve me now
let's see blood sucking Vampires will be
the only things that suck with these
viewing options and you can buy I mean
bet on it to go along with Nicholas Cage
as a vampire we've got the final season
premiere of everyone's favorite Hitman
turned drama student an exorcism movie
based on a real person some kick-ass
anime and an rt25 celebration pick
that'll make you get up and dance or
maybe not Rotten Tomatoes is looking to
awaken the devil inside you only if you
need a viewing partner on this week's
what to watch but if you were to stop
focusing on his needs what would happen
he won't grow to full power exactly he
won't grow to full power what that's so
weird why would you phrase it like that
but yes bringing shark fangs and pale
skin to a theater near you is the comedy
horror film Renfield one big reason to
check this one out is that it takes
characters from Bram Stoker's 1897 novel
Dracula and sets them in modern day New
Orleans get your beads ready telling
this new story is a loaded cast that
includes the Nicholas Cage as our boy
Dracula Nicholas Holt is the Title
Character Renfield and others like
Aquafina and Ben Schwartz and supporting
roles gosh I love them and critics are
bloody loving the film and it's cast so
far top critic Liz Shannon Miller from
consequence says that Renfield knows
exactly what it wants to achieve and
does so effectively anchored by its lead
performances there you betrayed me I
showed him how I really felt and he
betrayed me
thank you Bergman you got a visitor
firing off its fourth and final season
on HBO this week is the killer dramedy
series Barry okay first off if you
haven't seen the first three certified
fresh seasons and we're talking all
between 90 and 100 on the Tomato Meter
you're gonna want to do that 30 minute
apps fun premise easy watch go now do it
do it now once you do you'll understand
how it's managed to earn 44 Emmy Noms
over three seasons including outstanding
comedy series all three years and then
you'll run Matlock to your TV for what
has been declared the final season which
we know begins with Barry in prison and
dealing with the emotional aftermath of
the explosive season 3 finale and
besides being the last one what makes
this season even more intriguing is that
the show's Emmy winning star Bill Hader
also stepped behind the camera to direct
every episode something he did only
occasionally prior to this I mean dang
dude he's got some serious skills we
have more questions for you father Mort
you don't have a problem with me you
talk to my boss
another option that might awaken
something deep inside you is the Pope's
Exorcist opening in theaters let's be
honest the number one reason to see this
one is that it's inspired by a real
person father Gabriel amorth a famous
Italian priest who performed over 100
000 exorcisms for the Vatican
um what now the movie pulls from a
morse's various Memoirs and slapping on
that white collar to play him is Russell
Crowe in what's being described as his
first lead role in a horror film and if
you're still on the fence or should I
say Gates as in Gate of Hell no okay
then it's worth noting that critics are
somewhat into this one with the fresh 62
percent on the Tomato Meter
foreign
also heading to theaters this week is
the Japanese
anime in theaters from famed anime
director Makoto shinkai this one is
about a high school girl and a
mysterious man who are working to
prevent various disasters across Japan
and one of the people lending his voice
is hakuto matsumura who's also a member
of the Japanese pop group six tones I
have all their albums that's a lie but
if the sheer draw of anime and a pop
Idol isn't quite enough for you how
about that suzume is fresh at 93 on the
Tomato Meter in fact this movie opened
in Japan in November of last year and
became their fourth highest grossing
film of the year now it's our turn to
spend some money on it you walk out
there
and the music starts and you feel it
your body just moves there's something
inside of you that just clicks and
you're gone
it's like you're somebody else for a
while and finally as part of our rt25
celebration this pick is the 1983 movie
Flash Dance it's actually the 40th
anniversary of this romance drama making
it the perfect time to watch which stars
Jennifer Beals as a passionate young
dancer looking to become a professional
ballerina it marked the first
collaboration between legendary
producers Don Simpson and Jerry
Bruckheimer and ultimately some of the
music videoesque sequences they came up
with for this influenced other big films
of the decade like Footloose Purple Rain
and Top Gun and to that we say thank you
flash dance it may be rotten on the
Tomato Meter but critics loved beale's
performance and fans loved the whole
thing and sometimes the soundtrack can
be a real draw too in this case the film
had two songs up for best original song
at the Oscars and one for the song
Flashdance What a Feeling and if you
want that feeling you just gotta see it
okay wow what a strong and fun list sure
I'm biased but that doesn't make me
wrong right be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and don't
forget to check out the new rt25 page
where we're celebrating 25 years of
rotten tomatoes with plenty of fun
things including our brand new card game
putting your mind to the test on 25
years of Tomato Meter scores it's super
fun check it out that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay fresh
[Music]
foreign